hello america i'm mark levin and this is
life liberty and levin welcome
are we in the precipice of war
a major war
does it seem like as a nation we're
ready for such a possibility
are we ready
psychologically have our leaders
explained much to us
do we get much explanation from the
media in this country at the white house
press conferences or on the sunday shows
oh yes they talk about how many troops
are lined up against nato and that sort
of thing i'm not talking about that sort
of thing
and the ideologues well
they're in full-throated attack
the ideologues who talk about the
neocons and the federal contractors
and the others the isolationists who go
on and on about how we're provoking our
enemies
war is not about ideology
foreign policy is not about ideology
national security is not about ideology
the word that describes it best is
prudence
prudence
the wise judgment brought to very
difficult decisions and facts and issues
that's what we expect from our leaders
tell me does the department of defense
with the secretary of defense and the
head of the joint chiefs
do they seem like the very best people
in a position
to protect this country and safeguard
this country
should there be a war
how about the secretary of state does he
seem like the very best person
to use diplomacy to rally our allies and
and defend off our enemies
how about the national security adviser
do you know who the national security
adviser is
he was an operative
prior to serving in his current position
was also involved in the dirty tricks to
try and take out former president trump
uh with respect to russia collusion
how about congress
is this not the weakest congress we've
seen
in the modern era
not a lot of smart people in congress
not a lot of people who look at their
country first
you look at our country ladies and
gentlemen we're at each other's throats
why are we at each other's throats
because of this american marxist
movement
that seeks to destroy our history
support for our country as it is today
and in our classrooms on the border with
budgets violating separation of powers
you name it just turning the culture
inside out
is hollywood on our side
is corporate america on our side
are they just too too invested
in communist china and other regimes
that have designs on this country
and the united states military the
infantry the air force and the marines
and so forth do you think they're being
trained properly
many respects they are
but what about
critical race theory and transgenderism
in other events radical left events that
seem to take up way too much of their
time
and demoralize them
and what about the commander-in-chief is
he up to the job
the answer to all of this is
this is a disastrous domestic situation
facing a grave foreign policy situation
and there's very little prudence
involved
and that is a big big problem
so as we're fighting over the voting
rights act which has nothing to do with
voting rights and the rest of the
american marxist democrat party media
and academic
agenda
none of it has anything to do with
strengthening the united states military
our national security
and ultimately our self-preservation
none of it
if we had a real media in this country
you'd understand what's taking place
overseas
so we have to ignore the loudmouth
ideologues
who are endless interventionists in the
loudmouth ideologues
who seem to believe that hypersonic
missiles intercontinental ballistic
missiles
nuclear warheads stealth fighters and so
forth once they reach the american
border they stop
they're not a threat anymore
no we are in a uh serious pickle here
you might say
now whose fault is this obviously it's
the enemy's fault who's the enemy well
there's even debate over this
so much of our culture has been bought
off by the communist chinese regime you
can't even say anything like the china
virus say the spanish virus you can talk
about a white dominant society
but of course when you talk about the
communist chinese regime
that's what it is
but you're not allowed to talk about
that so how can you talk seriously about
the threat
when it comes to putin there's some kind
of a love bizarre relationship between
putin and a certain percentage of our
politicos in this country and media who
seem to think he's a pretty cool guy
he's a tough guy and so forth he's a
killer
he's a killer who killed his way to the
top he's corrupt
and he wants to hold on to power and he
wants to re-establish the old soviet
union which was defeated
during the cold war by reagan in the
united states and our allies
why should we defend the ukraine oh i
don't know
why should we defend belgium
italy
france great britain they're all the way
over there after all how are they over
there
how many wars have started in lawrence
kansas
i don't know of any do you
how many wars
in joplin missouri
none that i can think of
no
the wars are overseas and they have a
way of reaching into the united states
the fact of the matter is china
russia and they're not alone are
building militaries
against us
russia is not building a military
against ukraine
they don't need all that hardware all
that technology all those troops just
for ukraine
china's not building the biggest navy
killer satellites
and so forth because of taiwan
they're building them because of us
us the united states of america
do we act as a government
like we're serious about confronting
this
do we act as a government like we need
to become
more reliant on our own manufacturing
and our own products
do we act as a government that we need
to secure the border and make sure the
united states is safe from within
do we act as a government that we use
our financial priorities wisely
not redistributing wealth not creating
new massive entitlements not breaking
the back of the american taxpayer but
ensuring that our military has
everything it needs
to potentially fight more than a
any one region war
this is very very serious business
ladies and gentlemen
the hackers and the hawkers and the
soapbox loudmouths are not the people to
listen to
aoc does not have any experience when it
comes to the military
and most of the people in the senate
don't either but we the people
one day that may be our children and
grandchildren that have to fight
this isn't about hawks this isn't about
doves this is about prudence it's about
judgment it's about doing the right
thing
which then brings me to joe biden
you democrats
you people in the media
you people in academia
you brought us joe biden
you knew damn well
he was incapable of doing what a
president needs to do
for a whole variety of reasons
you knew that he was not mentally fit to
be president of the united states
you knew that experientially he's been a
disaster when it comes to foreign policy
you are responsible for the man who sits
in the oval office today you
you never trumpers who have a hate on an
obsession
that requires deep psychological
treatment
you
are responsible for the man who's in the
oval office today as i speak
what is congress doing about any of this
nothing
they're chasing down donald trump and
protesters
they're trying to change our voting
system for the worse
they're trying to nationalize what
belongs in the states
they're trying to create new
entitlements for people who don't work
and don't want to work
they're trying to redistribute wealth
they're trying to turn us into a
radicalized france is that a good idea
ladies and gentlemen no i don't think it
is
how many of our leaders are going on
television or radio and spoken to us
truthfully in a straightforward manner
about the threats that this function
this country faces
and that's russia and china what about
iran
iran is months away from having nuclear
weapons
this is a regime that makes it
abundantly clear what it intends to do
to us
let alone the arabs
and our allies the israelis
you think we can ignore this forever we
have an administration that's bending
over backwards
not just appeasing the iranians
paying them begging them to come to the
table and agree to an agreement that
they'll never honor
this is a regime that hates us
they are fanatics
they are zealots
they're not going to be persuaded
otherwise
i mean
even
muellers with nuclear weapons folks are
a threat
this is the situation today
you think america is ready
i think
a significant portion of the
population's ready
but i think a significant portion of
population is not so joe biden goes off
last week and gets an ice cream cone
as if he's some third grader
and as his people go on tv trashing
republicans
as if they're leaders of the third reich
and as the media in this country
with so many low iq inexperienced
radical leftists dressed up as
journalists
not just ignore the threat
fail to provide the american people with
the context for the threats we face
we're not ready
we're not ready
you don't have to believe me
just look at our enemies
they see this as an
opportunity a great opportunity
if not tomorrow maybe the next day if
not the next day maybe next year
they see the biden administration is the
perfect opportunity to act
the communist chinese are going to act
in one form or another putin is going to
act in one form or another i don't know
what they're going to do
but they see the weakness in the oval
office
they see the leadership of the defense
department millie who calls the head of
the communist chinese military
everything's going to be fine don't
worry about trump we'll let you know if
we attack
they see this
they see the pipeline between germany
and russia
and what biden did
they see our budget when it comes to the
united states military that this
administration congress are not serious
they saw what happened in afghanistan
where they're still american citizens
behind enemy taliban lines as well as
our allies they see our capitulation to
the iranian regime they see it all
they see weakness
that's why i said over a year ago who do
you think our enemy is rooting for for
president united states
donald trump
or joe biden
i think the answer was obvious then
it's obvious now